if you ask elon musk we might not be
driving ourselves much longer i think in
the future
people look back and say wow i can't
believe we had to drive these cars
ourselves but in the auto and tech
industries there's a divide over how we
get to that future you see most
autonomous driving companies are using
an array of sensors to help their
vehicles navigate including something
called lidar which is a laser-based
sensor that helps the car understand how
far away objects are but tesla says it
won't need lidar to get around and that
its cars will instead see the road using
cameras and artificial intelligence
and that's why i woke up at 1am to watch
tesla's ai day
because as well as unveiling 2021's
must-have halloween costume
[Music]
tesla also lifted the hood on the ai
that powers its advanced driver
assistance features known as autopilot
and full self-driving it's clearly
headed to way better than human without
question so why does this matter well
tesla has the highest stock market
valuation out of all automakers and has
ambitions to put tens of millions of
vehicles on the road in order to hit
that aim it's going to need consumers to
trust its technology but right now it's
current less advanced driver assistance
software autopilot is being investigated
by nutser after a string of crashes at
emergency scenes that's partly why my
colleague tesla reporter rebecca elliott
was also awake really late watching the
same presentation it was a super
technical
look at how tesla approaches some
difficult problems using artificial
intelligence so what's so different
about tesla's plans for automated
driving and what difference does it make
for consumers well i'm going to boil it
down for you buckle up let's go
firstly to understand what's unique
about tesla's approach you need to
understand the difference between
cameras and lidar
lidar is really good at understanding
distance and it's used by pretty much
every autonomous vehicle company at the
moment but while it's good at
understanding distance it can't see
visual information like road signs in
the way a camera can which is why most
companies use a combination of both musk
however has said he thinks lidar is a
crutch that will drive companies to a
local maximum that they will find very
difficult to get out of and so tesla is
trying to create a fully autonomous
vehicle that won't need lidar at all but
instead will drive itself mainly using
cameras kind of like a human uses their
eyes we must solve passive optical image
recognition we must solve it extremely
well now this isn't easy there's a
reason why other autonomous vehicle
companies haven't taken this approach
and have stuck with lidar on the same
day that tesla held its ai day waymo
released a blog post explaining that
they use complementary sensors including
radar lidar and cameras and not just
vision because camera only systems can
struggle in adverse weather and poor
lighting conditions and while cameras
can be good at visual information
they're not naturally as good as lidar
at understanding distance and at tesla's
ai day even musk himself admitted that
cameras can be fooled are you worried at
all since you don't have any depth
sensors on the car that people might try
like adversarial attacks pull some like
wiley cody stuff
you know like paint the tunnel on the on
the wall
i actually have a t-shirt with a stop
sign on it
and and then you like flash the car
it will it will stop
but tesla engineers did lay out how they
planned on getting around these issues
by training their ai to understand
images being gathered by the cars 8
cameras like being able to identify an
object's distance based on its size and
where it is in the field of view and
then make driving decisions based on
that information or as tesla puts it
we're trying to design a neural network
that processes eight cameras that are
positioned around the vehicle into what
we call the vector space and this is a
three-dimensional representation of
everything you need for driving and to
do that training they're building a
supercomputer called dojo it'll be a
fastest ai training computer which musk
said would be operational next year but
all of this is set to come in the future
and right now tesla's autopilot system
which comes as standard on all new
vehicles is the subject of an
investigation so what does all this mean
if you're a potential tesla buyer or
curious about the future of driverless
cars well that's where i need rebecca to
come in hey rebecca how's it going hey
george is the tech that was demonstrated
at ai day likely to become a reality
anytime soon musk is known for setting
super ambitious targets but the company
hasn't always
fulfilled
those ambitions or at least not in the
time frame that musk initially set out
two years ago musk said that he thought
tesla would have the robo taxi service
in place by the end of 2020. we expect
to have the first operating robo taxis
next year
that hasn't happened and you know
broadly speaking autonomous vehicles
have taken a lot longer to come to
reality than many in the industry
expected only criticism and it's a fair
one and sometimes i'm not on time but
i get it done right now tesla's under
investigation for crashes involving its
current autopilot system and i've
reached out to tesla about the
investigation and they didn't respond to
my request for comment but they have in
the past said that driving with
autopilot is safer than driving without
autopilot
so
what effect could these crashes and the
investigation have on tesla's plans
these investigations can lead to recalls
so they don't always but the probe
generally signals that federal officials
are paying closer attention to advanced
driver assistance systems which not been
tightly regulated in the u.s as with any
kind of emerging technology
gaining consumer confidence is
really important thanks rebecca yeah
thanks for having me
so if musk wants to meet his target of
20 million vehicles by the end of the
decade tesla is going to need to go
beyond its early adopters and
demonstrate to a broader audience that
its driverless technology is safe
hey if you're interested in the future
of how we get from a to b then don't
forget to subscribe and if you want to
read more of rebecca's coverage i've
left a link below catch you later
[Music]